[Music]
hey
everybody what's up
we were having a discussion in the
comments with all these [ __ ]
foreigners incorrectly using all kinds
of american terminology
a honky a honkler honk and a honky talk
are all
[ __ ] different concepts there
unrelated
although i'm now i'm kind of wondering
about the etymology of honky tonk
a hockey talk is a [ __ ] country
western well i know what it is but i
don't know what a bunch of hockeys
just white people yeah i guess so
somebody just like look that's a tank
full of honky snaps
let me make up my own [ __ ] come on i
think i think a hockey talk the talk is
just where they're
that i'm not sure exactly what it is i
think it's a party
i think we have to go back and look but
it's probably just that's what i mean
that's the funky party
it's probably what it [ __ ] means or
it probably means a bar
or something like that or a [ __ ] club
something like that
yeah i like well i like tonk full of
funkies
i can't even say that without cracking
up and then a honker
was [ __ ] some mean thing about
[ __ ] honking people's noses it's a
clown
thing i don't remember what it was let's
call it other people
clowns i i don't think
but that's dead that only lasted like
two weeks
yeah it's interesting like two you gotta
keep up yeah that was that that was that
was
awesome kind of mean man that's it it
had to do with clown world
honk hong kong i think even back in
[ __ ] even back in the [ __ ] 90s
people were saying stuff like that so
five minutes ago yeah it was like five
minutes ago and now it's like
that was five nano seconds ago it's like
yeah we've already moved on from that
you missed that train yeah
[ __ ] foreigners well i told them
right before we came on i said you know
everybody's a 400 to somebody
yeah we're off the whole world is full
of foreigners goddammit yeah
so we saw this movie last night this is
pretty good i liked it this is a pretty
decent flick gotta say it's called body
at brighton rock
yeah came out in 2019 it's actually
streaming on hulu at least in the united
states i don't know if it's on hulu
where you are or wherever
um this was actually the feature length
directorial debut of
uh roxanne benjamin she also britain
produced it
now her name sounded familiar so i
looked it up and there was an interview
with her in variety
she also directed us a few segments in
some anthology films vhs and i think she
produced that as well
i think in vhs2 she did one in
southbound which is also a really good
flick
and xx or double x which i think is on
shutter
um so she's kind of you know well known
she's been around for a while
producer director but this is her first
uh full-length movie
also i think from what i heard they're
going to let her helm
some creep show episodes uh in the next
season presumably and also she's working
on a remake of knight of the comet
from 1984 which i could see it i mean
this film
almost has kind it's not set in the 80s
it's said in the present day
but it has an 80s movie like just a fun
80s movie kind of vibe to it i thought
and there's like some 80s music into
who's the director again roxanne
benjamin okay yeah
and she she wrote and produced it too
yeah just a very straightforward
action horror kind of
movie it is like you said it has an 80s
tone it's like no nonsense there didn't
seem to be any kind of
[ __ ] messages in it or anything it
was just some girl trying to survive
this [ __ ]
yeah it's very simple it's very
straightforward it's just kind of like a
fun you know fun kind of creepy
kind of you know she's not a part she's
not a ranger she's not a park ranger
she's a park employee
so she doesn't really know how to
survive outside she's got to spend
spend the night outside lost up in i
guess it's redwood forest
uh it's uh it's uh the san jacinto
mountains i don't know where that is
that's where it is california yeah
california i've never been to that one
and um joe nash says what's your
drinking tom it's not alcohol this is
early in the day
no it's uh iced coffee it's iced coffee
and then
she has to stay out there and then
there's she doesn't really have any
even basic survival skills i mean she
was [ __ ] hooked
up with survival stuff i had a [ __ ]
slept sound man she had everything she
needed
and she was scared to death because
there's a dead body out there with her
yeah
well yeah okay so the the premise of
this there's a poor little girl named
wendy
she probably i mean she looks pretty
young uh the actress that played
about 1920 karina fontes yeah i was
thinking she was like 19 20 years old
yeah
so she works she works at this national
park
now prior to this she she says later
she's like you know i just give out like
maps and like you know sweep the kitty
trails and pick up trash and [ __ ] like
that
but it comes to pass that she ends up
getting an assignment
to go on one of the more difficult
hiking trails to put up some signs
uh she wasn't actually assigned that
because you know her friends kind of
like
[ __ ] on her about like you're an indoor
girl like why don't you just like work
in the museum and just leave the hard
[ __ ] to the rest of us that actually
have some experience but she's a little
bit stung by that
because she's kind of she doesn't say it
out loud but she's kind of like man i
could do this [ __ ] if i wanted to but
then there's like one of her friends who
was more experienced
who had that assignment of going out in
the harder like hiking trail
she wanted to stay on this other thing
so she could hang out with this dude she
had a crush with so they switched
so that's how that ended up happening
she did have all the right equipment she
did have all the [ __ ] but she
wanted to prove i guess to her friends
and colleagues that she wasn't
completely
useless that wasn't exactly how it went
though so this poor kid goes out on this
trail uh not surprisingly gets lost
while she is lost uh she calls you know
she radios in
and they're basically like she's not
exactly sure where she is because she's
lost her map and her you know gps on her
phone isn't working
so they're basically well you know we
don't know exactly where you are
so we will try to get to you as quickly
as possible but you know it's gonna be
dark soon and we will probably have to
wait until tomorrow and it's light out
because it's too dangerous to come out
in the dark
because it's you know out in the middle
of the [ __ ] wilderness so they're
like basically you have to stay here
all night and then maybe we'll come and
find you in the morning uh
which wouldn't be too bad except that
she's found a dead body
now this dead body um
everyone like i really really liked i
don't want to spoil it
okay i did guess where it was going
about
i don't want to say halfway through like
three quarters of the way through
i called it but you might not i don't
know you might not
because i'm not really sure it was hard
for me to tell how obvious it was she's
out there with this dead body dude phil
and his camp is there well
yeah you don't know if he fell you don't
know what to do you don't know if he got
murdered
because there's a tent there there's
some stuff
there's like some sounds then she sees
this other guy
yeah the guy the other guy stalking her
seems to be stalking her and stuff so
she's kind of threatened by this dude
she gets into kind of a confrontation
with him and then she [ __ ] also has
to deal with this damn bear
i guess the bears come and look for the
body i don't know yeah that's something
to eat
she gets attacked by a big old [ __ ]
brown bear
pretty good good movie i actually really
liked it yeah
and here's the thing about it though is
it because i was sitting there going
because we were watching it and she was
kind of sleeping
like right by where the dead body was um
and i was sitting there going well you'd
think that you wouldn't really want to
do that
but apparently well the woman that that
wrote and directed this movie
she actually had this job for a short
time
uh and she's like i didn't know this i'm
just presuming it's california and i
don't know if the law is the same now
but she's like when i had this job
when you were if you were out on in the
wilderness and you found a dead body
you were supposed to stay with it until
the authorities could come so they could
determine whether it was a murder or an
accident or whatever so the [ __ ] that
she says about is like you know you
can't leave you have to stay by the body
and like keep an eye on it until the
authorities can get there
that is true so i guess that was just
the standard operating position
yeah because some because for some of
the time i'm like is that the law though
because it's like you know you would
think if you could sleep in the whole
wilderness
as long as you're still in that same
area why would you want to sleep like
right there looking at this creepy acid
because the dead body looks pretty
creepy
like one of his eyes is all bugged out
and he's all [ __ ] up and everything
and uh you know she does kind of like go
and
throw the [ __ ] over the face and whatnot
but
she's just kind of like like sleeping
there by trying like looking at it
yeah but i guess that's why because that
that is an actual
rule so it shows what i was kind of i
liked the movie i was i was kind of
laughing because they were
saying they were telling her that we
would not be able to find you tonight
you're gonna have to sleep out there she
was [ __ ] losing it
but yeah well that's what that goes back
to what her friends were saying
before you're an indoor kid why don't
you just like stick to stick to working
in the gift shop or whatever because
that's what she usually did
she didn't really do anything out on the
harder trails that was like the older uh
rangers that had those jobs she was just
kind of like you know
because that's what the woman said like
you know because i said i read an
interview with her in variety
being infantry was just [ __ ] second
nature to me if this
if you watch this movie and this ever
happens to you people
don't [ __ ] worry you can sit down on
your haunches and roll up into a ball
or up on your knees and your [ __ ]
elbows like that and
soundly sleep without any blankets on as
long as it's not
too cold and you make it through the
whole night you won't even hardly you
won't even get a bug on you most of the
time
well it's comfortable comfortable well
and the thing about this is that i think
i mean because i think they said at the
beginning that they were talking about
uh frostbite warning so i'm assuming
that it was because i think that they
said at the beginning that it was
supposed to go down to the 20s
she had so much stuff so she had codes
and she had and then like she found
you know she found the body and then she
found a campsite and she found like so
she found like a better flashlight she
found a sleeping bag she had stuff she
had water
yeah and dudes cap dude's cap his uh
tent and all his stuff was in their
sleeping bag if you've ever lived
outside for extended periods of time
if that is a [ __ ] hotel
i could i could live the rest of my life
in there as long as i had food medical
treatment
just sleep outside even in pouring rain
you get you adapt to it and you just
you learn the skills to keep yourself
dry and [ __ ] wet and nice and
comfortable and
you're on a man [ __ ] it's it you get
very comfortable very quickly
in that environment well the thing about
it though is that it wouldn't be a
horror movie if somebody that knew
absolutely what they were doing it got
stuck out in the middle of i mean that's
the whole point of
you watching it oh yeah is that an extra
pressure it's this girl that doesn't
have any idea really i mean she had like
a little bit of training and she had
stuff it would have been like what would
happen if the random person
did it you know yeah that's what i mean
so i didn't find it all that and then
you stumble across a dead body and she's
just like i said she's just like 19 or
something like that
it's like i don't think i'd be too happy
about finding a dead body and then
radioing and being like oh guess what
you have to stay right by that keep an
eye on that [ __ ]
and uh probably it'll be like eight
hours from now before he could find you
um you know so just settle on in there i
mean you know i don't think i would have
been quite as freaked out as her
but it wouldn't be a fun situation um
now over eight weeks yeah that was
hardcore though
well yeah that's what i'm saying this is
like it's okay
you just like to show off about how yeah
i just said it well it's just kind of
funny it's like
it's like you know it's just like
something it's just like somebody
i can understand if if you don't have
any experience with it you know what i
mean how would be intimidating well yeah
it's just piece of cake piece of cake
don't if you ever get in that position
don't worry
grantham's hammer says another stalker
um i don't
like i said i want to spoil it not
necessarily
but maybe i don't know well here's the
thing i think that was the best thing
about this movie
is that it kept [ __ ] really ambiguous
till the end like not an
annoying ambiguous but just in the way
that it's like what is going on here
like did this dude fall did someone
murder this dude who is this other dude
like what exactly is going on so i
really really like that they kept that
uh suspense going
because i was sitting there going like
like i said about three quarters of the
way through
maybe a little bit sooner maybe two
thirds of the way i i called it
um well i got one thing wrong but then
later i was like oh no
it's this and then it did turn out to be
that which i liked i liked that they
ended it that way because i thought it
was kind of like a cool
i know who you are graham granthars well
he sent me he sent me an email so i sent
i remember you i got pictures of you is
that a threat
the way you said it kind of said i got
pictures of you if you know what i mean
little high school pictures i'm pretty
sure it's you
your blonde hair had glasses i think
back to well there you go
the mystery is solved and uh we were uh
in that damn black box [ __ ]
doing black box theater i got pictures
of you and steve
i think you had a saw in your hand
pretty sure that's you
well there you go yeah fourth door down
says you have to stay with the body
until spring
yeah uh you know
mango says you can always eat the body
if you have to wait that long
and then fourth drawer down says i've
seen movies you can hollow out a bear
and live in that
sure just like cutting open a taunton uh
but yeah this like i said you know this
is a very fake it's not
you know super deep it's not super it
was just like a fun
just had a nice tone to it very simple
very few characters um almost the entire
thing was her
in the woods and then this dead guy and
then this other guy that kept
popping up um and you weren't entirely
sure what his motives were
what the [ __ ] situation was and uh
you know
pretty good film i thought camper says
no that was andrew
it may have been i don't know i that i'd
have to see you again i could put a
put your face to that name been a long
time
you were kind of on the periphery we
didn't hang out that much
you and steve hung out more than i did
yeah and that's before i moved there
because he said he said in the email
that he just saw the link to the podcast
on like a friend of a friend's
facebook i think i was only there a year
and then i came back later and was there
another couple
couple years on top of that after
graduation oh okay yeah i think it was
only there a year or two years maybe
it's been a long time you know what's
funny why were we talking about this the
other i don't know why i just uh
i just was reminded of this but we were
talking about and maybe people in other
parts of the us can
tell me now when i graduated from high
school in 1990
right now as far as i know i don't know
about all of florida
but everywhere you know in central
florida as far as i know
high school was three years it was 10th
grade 11th grade
12th grade and then you graduated junior
high was 7
8 9 elementary school was 1 through 6.
now later
after you know many years after i was
out they changed it to
high school being four years uh you know
middle school
being six seven eight and then
elementary school being k through five
um but that's not the way it was when i
went to school weird so when i told him
that my high school was only three years
he thought it was super weird
i was like it's not like that anymore
it's four years now but that was like
many years after i graduated i was just
wondering how it was
and it used to be called like 789 grade
789 used to be called junior high now
it's called middle school
yeah middle school but that was several
years after i had graduated well i think
junior high might have been about three
to like like like six seven eight
i think i might have been junior high
well that's what middle school is now
now they call it middle school when i
was
when i was growing up and when i was in
it was called junior high and it was
seven eight nine yeah elementary school
was kindergarten through sixth grade
although i didn't go to kindergarten
because you have to now but you didn't
have to when i was little
yeah our high school was four same in
brazil two it was four
four years well like i said i think that
it's like that everywhere now but when i
was growing up for some reason where i
grew up in florida and other places that
i knew of um
it wasn't it was just three years high
school in brazil was far superior than
it was
into michigan it was a smaller crowd
[ __ ]
higher end than it was just a [ __ ]
constant party and it was a private
school so the teachers just
the teachers were like [ __ ] they were
only a little most of them were only a
little bit older than you and they let
you do whatever they want what you what
you wanted
and you ran into them in clubs you're
drinking with the did you learn anything
though
oh yeah there's ib programs there
you guys can go you guys can go um
search it it's on
it was a [ __ ] super high-end school i
wouldn't have been able to afford to go
to it if it
if it well no because bill later on when
my mother
married bill you know he actually paid
for it um
too but it started out as government
dependent i was there it was called
escola graduated sao paulo it's in
brazil
brazilian pres that's where all the
brazilian federal government people went
brazilian presidents and [ __ ] their
children [ __ ] went there
it was there for a long time it was an
international school spoke english
and you just look at the damn um
oh what do you call it the
demonstration video of trying to get you
to get your kid to go there
that's the way that school was [ __ ]
fantastic
and it was like uh globalist as hell man
[ __ ] it was for the elites
those kids were [ __ ] rich south rich
brazilians are richer than
[ __ ] rich uh saudi arabians that's
how rich you're talking
yeah palaces and [ __ ] they don't even
worry about any laws
like no gun laws in brazil you know guns
are illegal except for them they got
machine guns and [ __ ]
underground [ __ ] rifle ranges and
[ __ ] private guards and
who are [ __ ] ex-special forces and
[ __ ] ex-police
and [ __ ] it's just it's sickening
when you actually see it it's [ __ ]
sickening
i hated it i hated that scene yeah
yeah yeah see i'm i'm
kind of said louis said in la elementary
was one through five junior high was six
through eight and high school was nine
through 12.
that's um yeah and it seems like that
seems to be the norm now but i guess it
wasn't when i was growing up
um i just assumed that it was like that
all over the country but i guess it
wasn't
because everywhere i knew of in central
florida was
k through 6 7 8 9 and then high school
was 10 11 12.
it was three years three years you know
six years three or three years
i don't know it's it's really weird like
i said i think it's all changed
now but i don't know very very odd
um yeah so i was going to say something
else oh um
somebody said something about a bear
attack this kind of this didn't really
remind me of that but just i guess
because it was about a bear and i can't
remember what the name of the [ __ ]
movie was man i just saw it not too long
ago we might have even reviewed it i
can't remember if we did or not
but there was a movie that was on
shutter netflix something like that and
it was basically
based on it was loosely based on a real
story
that was a couple and they were camping
out in the woods
and uh the boyfriend got
maul like killed by the bear and it was
like really i remember the special
effects and it's been really really
gross it looked like really really
realistic
and then basically the bear wanted to
eat the woman as well
so she had to kind of like crawl her way
back to civilization like while this
bear was [ __ ] stalking her
i can't remember the name of it but it
was actually really really good and
you know i i can still remember the dude
all [ __ ] he got torn out of the tent
and he was just like all [ __ ]
he was all torn up like laying out the
thing and like i said i'm pretty sure it
was based on a real true story
i don't know why i can't remember the
name of it i think there's like one word
like it wasn't grizzly that was one from
the 70s
[ __ ] man what are you doing over there
looking for pictures i got it
oh okay you got it okay let's see that's
it let's see
[Music]
that's where i went to high school oh
okay it has g uh middle
it has all grades from kindergarten to
12th and it's just kind of separated up
into different
sections i wonder why they don't do that
here more
well that's cool it all that school had
about eight languages going on in it
yeah let's try to see if there's
okay
yeah it had elevators in it
[Laughter]
yeah trying to get some um
they're talking about the arts center
and stuff
there that's what it looked like outside
it's in sao paulo brazil
well there you go yeah oracle said i
attended a three-year
high school myself in missouri so it
wasn't just here that it was
doing that like i said i never really
thought of it as weird until everybody
started to
say different [ __ ] about it
okay you're talking about the robotics
lab
and [ __ ] yeah they've they've [ __ ]
another thing i always thought was funny
too because i you know everybody saw the
john hughes movies and like all the high
school movies
from the 80s and i used to think it was
so funny
that all the high schools were like
enclosed they were like inside
because the ones in florida you know
it's
the weather's hot down here so it's like
obviously the classrooms and [ __ ] and
buildings
but in between all the classrooms are
it's open it's just like sidewalks and
stuff
so it looks a lot more like i don't know
i don't know what it looks like but it's
not all it's not all enclosed in one
building
now one the elementary school that i
went to for a year
uh way back in the 70s
that was all enclosed but that was a
really really old building in a really
really old
neighborhood so then when i went to the
newer school
later that one was like all outside
man's gone brazil to trenton had the
head it went
it went back and forth um my step-dad
my mother was in the state department at
the time and
my step-dad was uh he wasn't from
trenton but he was uh
working for a company outside back
country thank you louie yes that was it
yeah but yeah he was uh you know hey i
get to answer questions too and
interrupt you so what were you saying
it doesn't matter that's [ __ ] private
[ __ ] i just let me talk about it
let's just you know my mother married a
guy who works down there
yeah so you went back and forth a lot
yeah yeah he
he was from michigan but he uh worked in
brazil and then later on moved to brazil
so we were moved back back and forth a
couple of times
yeah because he had a business down
there yeah down manufacturing facility
yeah yeah it says uh in south africa we
only have primary school which is grades
one through seven then high school which
is grades eight through twelve
that's interesting yeah i don't know
it seems like they're kind of all
similar everywhere but it's just
interesting how they
break them up you know i don't know why
they don't do more
[ __ ] like that where it's just all the
remember back in the old days like i
remember reading the [ __ ]
little house and the prairie books and
[ __ ] like that these little bitty towns
like out of the [ __ ]
out in the prairie and you'd have one
schoolhouse and then you'd have all the
kids in there
it's like a little bit like
five-year-old kids and like 18 year old
kids and they're just like all
like that must have been a [ __ ]
nightmare you have to keep them separate
in the modern world
well yeah obviously yeah that that
school that i just showed you they were
separate you had
there was a big distance between the two
it was a big complex yeah
they didn't they didn't interact they
took the buses together
to get there yeah like the school buses
but once they were there everybody
but i mean it was all in one area though
it was like large like a like a
big huge huge campus college campus
right
which okay like i said i don't know why
they don't do that more here they keep
the middle schoolers and their little
kids away from the high school areas
because
it was [ __ ] wild and back in our days
it was wild yeah well yeah
yeah there were drugs going on but it's
just like everywhere
those kids abused [ __ ] because their
families ran that country and partially
owned that country they couldn't be
arrested
and they had nearly unlimited money so
they could get their hands on any recipe
for disaster yeah they could get their
hands on anything and they couldn't
really be punished
so you know what i mean they'd be in
there and they didn't sell
drugs what the [ __ ] would you sell drugs
for for money they didn't give a [ __ ]
about that yeah they gave this [ __ ] away
for free
yeah you want some coke just like that
let's go snorkel mind if i do yeah
go to my house we'll snort
[Laughter]
yeah all this [ __ ] imported scotch
and [ __ ] shivers regal shivers royale
and [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i mean a
damn
200 bottle 200 bottle of scotch over
brazil which is more than [ __ ]
what your average poor family made in
like about three months worth of work
they're sitting there and figuring
drinking oh that's terrible pouring it
down to dragon [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy that's nice yeah it's dead
yeah
there's my dad i'll just buy enough yeah
i know yeah they had old whole damn
[ __ ]
room twice the size of this room just
nothing with racks of booze in it
because they'd have [ __ ] they'd have
huge parties at those places they were
they lived in like castles basically
not like castles but compounds big walls
around them yeah
yeah and you know they look well they
look like celebrity houses here you know
with their own gyms and gymnasiums and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] you know
pool complexes and looked like you were
like
they look like the facilities for a
whole apartment complex but no it's for
one house
you know what i mean yeah but it looked
like something for an apartment complex
here's a question for you are brazilian
women nuts or is it just an act
no they're nuts the richer they are the
more nuts they are too
well that i feel like that's true of any
situation because
if you have a lot of money then you're
insulated from consequences totally
pampered
totally pampered histrionic
personalities uh they have the hot girl
complex
how hot i didn't date them i only dated
middle-class
uh brazilian girls who were kind of like
the the kids of the professionals which
would be like the doctors and the
lawyers
so fairly normal people fairly normal
right they lived kind of like normal
people here in the united states
yeah but in brazil they would have been
considered poor
because there was no real middle class
it was very very small
it was just a [ __ ] ton of poor people
and a small amount of basically
oligarchs that ran it
and they were they were mafias basically
like something you'd see in colombia
yeah yeah oh if you crossed them they'd
kill you no problem
well yeah and they'd hire the cops to
kill you you so you you had to be on a
good
good i mean they weren't as bad as like
saddam saddam and his family
but some kind of kind of they were a
pain in the ass
well yeah you know but saddam's sons and
just run around see some woman with some
dude you know what i mean they just
raped a wife
yeah what what could you do you know
what i mean they'd kill you
yep couldn't do it they weren't that bad
yeah but you know what i mean
that's they worked yeah you know i'm
just saying
but they were a lot of them were bad
david june says i went to a school that
was all one building
town had less than a thousand people
leymus mascot too
it was a rock it wasn't really yeah
you know what the mascot for my high
school was the sand crabs
because it's on the beach you know the
school's on the beach
it's so close it was literally across
the street from the beach so you could
leave
uh the campus for lunch you had 50
minutes so
half the camp they'd wear bathing suits
under their clothes and they would just
go over there and lay in the sun or go
swim in the ocean not lunchtime yeah
that's what you did so we done with
talking with everybody today
i guess so all right we'll go ahead and
we'll let it go we covered we covered
the movie yeah it's a good movie
it's a good fun movie yeah it's pretty
different like i said it's not super
deep or anything like that it's just
kind of like a throwback
i liked about it is that the uh the edit
was good the tone was good
you know there wasn't any really there
wasn't any slow spots in it and there's
nothing in it nothing about the movie
pissed me off
it was amusing and as i said i liked the
ambiguity of it in the middle where you
weren't really sure
it's kind of like a twilight zone
episode yeah like you weren't really
sure what had happened to the dude or
who this other dude was and where the
bear was because you knew there was a
bear around there somewhere yeah just
because there's a bear on the poster
so there is a bear in the movie um but
yeah so
totally decent i think mango said it was
on um shutter in the uk
uh and amazon prime here it's on hulu
might be on amazon prime too probably
because a lot of times there's overlap
there
but yeah so uh we'll be back it's
tuesday right
yeah okay so we'll be back tomorrow
night for our wednesday night party
stream
yeah hopefully not get now we're not
incoherent i'm not gonna let it happen
we might you know what we might talk
about because hulu
just added a [ __ ] ton of like old movies
like old horror movies and old others
they had like mars attacks and a whole
bunch of other stuff
they added all three omen movies yeah we
watched one of them last night so we
watched the first domain let's even
though i've seen it a million times but
the second one and the third one i
haven't seen in a really long time so
now i'm kind of curious to watch them
i've seen them but
not since i was a kid yeah we'll check
them out yeah so tomorrow evening at 5
p.m eastern standard time
be here and we'll drink and talk about
whatever the [ __ ] we feel like talking
about it'll be super fun
and like i said hopefully we'll be able
to keep it together till the end
all right so we'll see you guys tomorrow
thanks for dropping by like always
bye